yes your your your your club is also the
comedy I mean you must be ecstatic aware
the club is now the trajectory of the
club it's the hottest it's the hottest
conjecture is a big word from me
I know but it's the hottest comedy club
in America right now I'll do to me I
know I know I know you're responsible by
put my you should you should how do you
how are you feeling about it now I mean
it's insane I wish my mom could see it
you know yeah she can walk in and and
feel it yeah I mean because the energy
is back yeah every room is sold out on a
weeknight and not only that now they're
adding new main room shows like earlier
shows that wasn't even possible in the
2000s or elem 90s I mean during with the
in the late 90s when I was there I was
working the door sometimes on a Saturday
night in there or you would get 20
people I'm not kidding you
it was really bad and I don't know what
but now it's transport I can tell you
why why yeah I'll tell you why
well you know there was a lot of there
was a time where my mom wasn't well and
then you're scared to take away the
business from her yeah you know name me
yeah because it's her business
yeah but then eventually like we brought
in like consultants you know Mom over
there Consultants cleaned it from top
down I had computers you know all that
crap yeah just going through all the
little things and then Tommy's gone yeah
you don't even mean because he was
holding on and not letting people grow
and he wasn't looking at as a business
stealing stealing yeah but you know what
I mean he was stuck in some weird time
period time period yeah and then we add
them right yeah and Eric is great right
and just clean just cleaned it clean it
and once the money started coming in
then you put it back in the business
clean up the carpets that you know I
mean all there's a bathroom yeah just
all that stuff and then when you do that
all the comics are like whoa and then
they stole it Rogan came back and this
one came back
and everyone just started coming back
and then all the comics now with their
social media Chris D'Elia
Eliza Whitney everyone's got like
hundreds of thousands of followers and
they tweet oh I'm coming to the Comedy
Store Marc Maron buh-buh-buh so if every
comic you mean we all bring in people
and it's a great environment it just
flows and everyone's having a good time
yeah so it was like you know also the
you you guys were a little bit more
lenient about bringing in people that
are not developed from the story yeah
yeah for sure because there used to be a
rule where it was I don't know said or
not but you would have to almost be
raised at the store or be a store that
only made sense when my mom was there
yeah after that it didn't make sense
anymore
it didn't make sense yeah no because
there's no mid sea shore there to
develop the app right that's it yeah she
was yeah I was like one of the last
comments that she passive Arabs yeah and
the developed yeah and so I was great
back then too yeah was because she you
know she liked to shoot dude she didn't
Rosanna all the different comics yeah
there was also a feeling at the Comedy
Store in the nineties where it was like
the Old West
yeah where you got to see things and
participate that you would [ __ ] I mean I
remember eating a girl's [ __ ] out and
let's stare away I mean they were just
you know do anything I remember eating
your [ __ ] in the stereo but that was
also like just like no rules or like but
comics he'd go through three hours
that's the another thing that lack then
yeah like Eric Eddie Griffin and guys
like that would go up and do Carlos Reef
Carlos Mencia would do 3-4 hours
and wouldn't let us go up and then you
sue if you got a spot that doesn't
necessarily mean you're gonna go up now
if you go over you're gonna get [ __ ]
in trouble you have to do your time I
heard Mencia was earlier and I wouldn't
even didn't even get to go up mmm so
it's like you have it there's like rules
now and it's there's a law and that it's
just I think that makes the club so much
better make makes one other people want
to go there and well I've always thought
you know that the calm
so was the star yes and they're the
stars are not the stars you know you
have to respect it's an institution yeah
you have to respect the rules yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]